welcome back one problem number 13 and
actually did I started problem for 13 at
the end of the last video and then I
realized when I was going through the
choices that I wasn't explaining it
actually perfectly correct I have to
admit this is the first problem that if
any of the problems we've seen on the
SATs is probably the one that's the
wording is probably the most difficult
to interpret but I think I figured it
out now so they're saying Kyle's lock
combination consists of three two digit
numbers the combination satisfy 3
conditions below one number is odd what
number is odd one number is a multiple
of five so we'll just write that as x 5
and then one number is a day of the
month of kyle's birthday day of one of
his birthday and actually this is what
confused me it actually matters that
it's his birthday not that it's just a
day of the month and I'll show you why
so let's say we have choice a choice a
so and let me let me color code these
conditions so odd I'll do in this blue
color let me say in x 5 i'll doing this
yellow color and then let me take
another good color the brown the day of
the month of his birthday during this
brown color so the first choice and let
me just write these down in a fairly
neutral color under this magenta so
choice a says 14 20 and 13 so we can do
is let's see we have one of the numbers
has to be odd and only one of the
numbers right so let's say this one this
satisfies the odd condition it actually
only satisfies the odd condition then
let's see what number here is x 5 a
multiple of 5 well this number let me do
it in the yellow this number is a
multiple of 5
and then finally what if that was the
multiple five which one has to be the
day of the month of his birthday what's
this choice right here now what confused
me when I first did this problem and
probably confused you as well it says if
each number satisfies exactly one of the
conditions exactly one exactly one right
so that to me that means that it can
only satisfy one of the conditions and
what confused me was that 20 satisfies
multiple five but to me 20 could just as
easily be be a day of a month of a day
of the month right but what the problem
that this that this encounters is here
we have to kind of assume that the 14th
is his birthday because if let's put it
this way if the 20th was his birthday if
the it this works if and only if the
14th is his birthday which it could be
and if the 14th is his birthday then 20
doesn't satisfy the day of the month of
his birthday it satisfies a day of the
month it wouldn't satisfy the day of a
month of his birthday I know that might
seem a little technical but I think
you'll see why I have to make that
distinction as you're going to choice B
choice B says is we did in that neutral
color it's 14 25 and 13 so here once
again 13 satisfies the odd criteria we
could say that 14 will assume that his
birthday is the 14th I mean we don't
know they haven't told us but it could
be right that's what they're asking what
could be the combination of the lock so
we'll say that the 14th could be his
birthday and then if the 14th is his
birthday what is 25 satisfy well 25 now
satisfies the odd criterion and it
satisfies the multiple of five criteria
so this this option choice B does not
work because 25 satisfies two of the
criteria and I know what you're saying
well look in toys a doesn't 20 satisfy
two criteria doesn't it satisfy that it
could be a day of the month and what I'm
saying is is if we assume that the 14th
is his birthday then twenty does not
satisfy
the day of his b'day right we're
assuming that the 14th birthday I want
you to think that about 20 it satisfies
a potential day of the month but if we
assume his birthday is the 14th then
obviously 20th is not the 14th and we
can go through the other choices choi c
choice C says 15 let me do it in neutral
color 15 18 16 and here well let's say
one of them has to be odd there's only
one odd option here it's this one one of
them has to be a multiple five well
there's no multiples of five here so we
know that C is not the right answer d
2015 20 2015 20 well here we I mean we
have two of the same numbers so they're
going to satisfy the same criteria so
that you either going to satisfy two
criteria or that each couldn't satisfy
none and they actually both satisfy you
know there's only one odd one here so
they both have to you know one of the
20s have to add satisfy the day of the
month of his birthday but then if the
day of the month of his birthday is 20th
and then we used the multiple of five as
being the 20th as well then both of
these numbers satisfy the day of his
birthday and a multiple of five so that
can't be the choice and then e choice e
let me do it in neutral color again is
30 for 30 21 and c 34 it's not odd it's
not a multiple five and it can't be a
day of the month of someone's birthday
so that one doesn't work I think these
three are obvious to you why they don't
work here the subtlety is is that this
criteria isn't just a day of the month
the criteria doesn't just say any number
between you know one and 31 it has to be
the day of the month of his birthday so
we have to kind of pick we have to say
well let's assume that his birthday is a
14th if his birthday is the 14th then
this is the day of the month of his
birthday then 20 is of course not the
day of the month is British so doesn't
satisfy this criterion it only satisfies
times fine
so that's how you have to think about it
and I have to have to completely admit
that that I think this is a little bit
of a too nuanced question out of you
know the five tests we've done so far
this is the first one that I have to
take a little bit of off time to figure
out on my own let's move on to the next
problem well now if we have that one out
of the way all right problem number
fourteen just hope you don't face that
when you take the s80 square root of x
plus 9 is equal to X minus 3 and they
say for all values of x greater than 3
so x is greater than three the equation
above is equivalent to which of the
following so we could is for x is
greater day let's see where this goes so
let's let's square both sides of this
equation let's square both sides just to
get rid of the square root sign so the
left-hand side I'm switch colors becomes
X plus 9 and then we just have to
multiply that out so that becomes x
squared x times x and then minus 6x plus
9 right you have too much if x x minus 3
is minus 3x and when you multiply it
again you get minus 3x again and if you
don't remember how to do this you might
want to just multiply out X minus 3
times X minus 3 we're going back to this
so this is the the relation and they
want to write in terms of X so let's
subtract 9 from both sides and we get x
is equal to x squared minus 6x and that
is choice C and we are done and the
reason the reason why they said x is
greater than 3 is because they actually
well they wanted they didn't want you to
take the negative square root right then
what they didn't they wanted you to make
sure that this is the positive square
root next problem problem 15
15 how many integers in the set of all
integers from 1 to 100 inclusive are not
the square of an integer so it's 1 to
100 inclusive so it includes 1 and 100
so what we have to think about is how
many squares are there between 1 and 100
well 100 is 10 squared 1 is 1 squared so
every number between one and 10 squared
is going to be in this range right 2
squared so these are the numbers who
squares 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and of course
those are 10 numbers right so there are
10 numbers you know one square is 12
squares for all of these numbers are
going to be between 1 and 100 inclusive
so all of these numbers are there
there's ten of them so how many of them
are not a perfect square it's going to
be a hundred minus 10 minus these 10
numbers so it's 90 which is choice e
I'll see you in the next video